كان وقت الالتحام هذا متقدمًا قليلاً عن
الجدول الزمني
المقرر أصلاً للرسو
أثناء غروب الشمس المداري ، ولكنه كان قادرًا فقط على
جعل لمعان الشمس على
السيارة مباشرة
عند الالتحام في الساعة 801 مساءً من
محطة الفضاء المركزية التي من المقرر إطلاقها
هذا الصيف
و soyuz  الفتحة مفتوحة
الساعة 1007 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي ،
تكون الوحدة التي تم إرساؤها
حاليًا على الجانب المواجه للأرض من
محطة الفضاء الدولية
، منفذ إرساء على الجزء الروسي
يسمى وحدة روسفيت
بمساعدة قائد المحطة الفضائية
أوليغ كونونينكو كريستينا
طباخ ناسا  أول واحدة من خلال
الفتحة استقبلها زملاؤها على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية
رحلتها الأولى إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية
نيك هاج من ناسا ، الرحلة التالية من
خلال الفتحة
تحية حارة من قبل طاقم بعثته 59 من
زملائه وبالطبع قائد سويوز
أليكسي أوشينان أحضر  يصل المؤخرة
للمرة الثانية على متن محطة
الفضاء الدولية طاقم محطة الفضاء الدولية
bac  k يصل عدد سكانها إلى ستة أفراد
البعثة 59 سيتولى القائد أوليغ كونونينكو
مع قائد سويوز أليكسي
من الصين القيادة من
كونانكو